ciao a tutti bentornati sovranità stress
oggi vi di un po diverso dal solito
andrò a riprodurre cioè a seguire il
tutorial di bob rose è la prima volta
che provo a dipingere specialmente con
la pittura ad olio che è più complicata
e quindi sta che non riusciranno super
schifezza è qualcosa di incredibile
speriamo io seguirò il tutorial passo
per passo e poi alla fine però pulire
con i due quadri quello di bob rock che
ovviamente è bravissimo con il mio
allora chi è bob ros era un pittore
americano che c'è un programma in tv in
cui faceva dei tutorial su come
dipingere a olio è diventato molto molto
famoso più che altro dopo la sua morte
purtroppo perché i suoi tutorial sono
molto rilassanti di persone lo guardano
non proprio per imparare a dipingere ma
perché i suoi tutorial sono super e
rilassanti ha una voce molto rilassata
ed è una persona supersimpatica e super
bowls e soprattutto quindi e i suoi
video anno milioni di più se è proprio
perché da sempre guarda per rilassarsi
penso che sia stato tipo il creatore
della sr quasi ho portato un po a
scoprire la sm r
anche io cercherò di parlare in modo
abbastanza rilassato ma non troppo
perché non voglio che vi addormentate
diciamo che il mio sogno di cozze strada
senza tranquillo durante tutto questo
video non so quanto durerà il video non
so quanto tempo ci metterò essendo anche
la prima volta quindi vi consiglio tv
mettersi comodi ripassati mettere il
video tutto schermo prenderci il nostro
tennis a down patatine pop corn e mi
siamo subito un'idea con che cosa con
minime ok ragazzi primo step che botolo
specie di fare e ricoprire l'attesa di
vita bianca io purtroppo non ho le
stesse tinte di qualità e più anche
sbagliato prendere quelle stabia anche è
alzato comprendere un altro tipo vabbè
comunque andiamo ricoprirla di
biancospino bene
[Musica]
ok ho fatto la mia prima passata di
bianco e già c'è qualcosa che è andato
storto perché è un po non lo fanno si
spalma molto bene forse perché attento
non è stato quello che è stato lui che è
un altra cosa forse ho usato
semplicemente la tinta olio bianca se
sapete dipingere il prodotto pittura
olio si tiene sveglio solamente tra foto
scrivetemi pure i vostri consigli
chiarimenti nei commenti sono super
curiosa ora ok andiamo già a fare le
parti del cielo e lo fa così
naturalmente sembra così il bar cirio ma
sono sicura che non sarà prendiamo come
so che questa è la nostra palette che
poggia provate che ho già preparato
prima con i colori e simili su aspettano
cadere albergo o dirlo e riesce bene a
te la meriti tema del verde quindi li
fai clic prof
lui ha sviluppato questa tecnica che si
chiama wet wet bagnato sul bagnato che
immagino che consiste appunto nel
dipingere sul non asciutto quindi con la
mano di bianco non aiuta correggetemi se
siete esperti di grosso dio è diventato
rosa no
ora praticamente per il prossimo un
passaggio mischia e blu con il rosso
nuovamente il suo è diverso dal mio
e spero che esca qualcosa di indecente
allora prendo un po di rosso
[Musica]
mi piace che facciate sfumature un po
rosse un po blu però non si sta sfumando
fedele come in altri treni che occupare
perché poi dopo dentro ci mette il blu
sapete
[Musica]
ok questo è il massimo del risultato
siamo riusciti a raggiungere per le
cupole non è perfetto come il suo banco
si avvicina comunque ora andiamo sfumato
di sedi sorprendendo pulito e giusto non
sufficiente andare attrezzo attrezzato
leggermente natura verso deciso con le
nostre strade
[Musica]
io un matisse un mattino basta dicembre
ora finora la cosa più difficile sono
queste nuvole che fa quando la social
lasciano dopo un po di blending è la
parte di sotto anche e ovviamente non
somiglia permette al padre di buon cross
ma me lo immaginavo che comunque ora
continuiamo ora andiamo a fare una
montagnetta qua
speriamo bene
[Musica]
[Applauso]
le montagne qua è purtroppo con tonio
forte con il pennello non con lo
strumento che sta utilizzando quindi
siamo uscite così così però pensiamo
peggiorate le condizioni della mia mano
conviene
io ora proviamo a fare la sfumatura che
sarà difficilissima quella di gruppo per
fare io provo con questo pennello perché
non ho altro
[Musica]
sky
tale scelta presso quello di novara
metterla dentro
perfetto
[Musica]
ok abbiamo fatto gli alberi sono
contenta perché è l'unica cosa che mi è
uscita in modo un po decente e poi
l'ombra
qua sotto gli alberi ora vediamo
cos'altro dobbiamo pagare siamo quasi
arrivati alla fine
la squadra di crescere
perché
questa gente ascolta signora che ho
fatto gli alberi mi sembra un po più
carino forse perché è un po più di
dimensione
ora continua a fare un po di verde qua
come disse il pod
adesso che fermava in calo fra molte le
mosche definisco di aste nato
atri
o capparoni ha quindi come preoccupare
certa inversione
sono mai usa in treno
[Musica]
ok ora andiamo a fare con del verde
scuro
andiamo a fare dei riflessi sugli alberi
qui niente
cercare di farlo più chiaro perché come
potete vedere su quattro molto più
bellissimo il mio è perfetto
c'è una sfumatura moto più chiara dover
decorate che caos la mia palette quindi
va cosa genera un altro po di verde
chiaro o scuro
[Musica]
punto
che team oracle il prossimo passaggio
e quindi fa delle sfumature da chi
[Musica]
colore cambia senza esponente di
detenzione
[Musica]
bravo di testa da signore
questo abbiamo messo molto scuro
o
[Musica]
che non troppo
questo d'arte
gli altri
[Musica]
a capua vetere con ad adesso
23 governo mai ha chiesto ai altro
[Musica]
bianco
giusto
[Musica]
certamente diverse
a quella riunione devo fare tutto
quindi forse alcune stradine
[Musica]
il 70
incorniciarla media sky
[Musica]
ok è finito finalmente questo è il
risultato finale
ho le mani sporche e sporcato un pacco
ovunque che per terra ovunque comunque
in confronto a quello bellissimo del dio
bo cross e molto molto diverso
però pensavo un system peso e c'è un
sacco di tempo quante ore sono passate
tre ore e mezzo per completarlo e
comunque sono abbastanza contento per la
prima volta che si può però ho pensato
molto peggio cross bravissimo spiegare
ha messo dimenticata di fare la firma
allora vedendola da vicino di errori si
notano molto di più è bruttissimo che è
stata vicino e voto più bello visto da
lontano evidenziando la differenza
faccio il paragone è ora metto la mia
firma qua non so se si mischierà con gli
altri colori essendo fresco o troviamo
ok ragazzi fatemi sapere cosa ne pensate
se mi piace per vr l'assalto di tutto
nei commenti
e se vorreste vedermi un altro episodio
anche se ci vuole il magico quattro ore
per farlo potevi sapere se evoluzioni
delle un'altra punta dell'estate un bel
like su questo video era che la sua 4
caselline su cui cliccare tutte le
riconoscono il video cliccate su quella
che preferite e buona visione